تحكي هذه الصور قصة ذئب
يقترب من حديقة منزلية متنقلة في
منتصف النهار الأسبوع الماضي ، بن ويلسون ، موظف
هناك فوجئ بحجمه ، لم يكن
يبدو مثل أي ذئب رأيته من قبل ، وكان الأمر
متروكًا لصدري ، فأنا في الثامنة من عمري ،
كان على الأقل في معدتي ، وحيث
يوجد واحد هناك عادةً اثنان ،
تحقق من هذا الفيديو لزوج يُشاهد يهرول
على طول مشروع تريل هجين في
كاليفورنيا ، وقد شاهدت هذه الصور على الإنترنت ، ولم يشاهد ذئب البرية
أو ذئب البراري في
كاليفورنيا صورًا أو صورًا من ذئب البراري في كاليفورنيا. لم يسبق له مثيل غرب المسيسيبي وهي
ليست حدثًا طبيعيًا هو
أن شيئًا من صنع الإنسان
عادة ما نجمعها معًا لصنع
نوع من الهجين لماذا تتجول
الآن بعض التكهنات بالفيضانات أو حرائق الغابات التي
أثرت على المحميات أو أن
أصحابها يطلقونها في
السكان البرية في تلك المنطقة لاستنشاق
الحلول لأن رؤية الذئاب أو
أي شيء يخرجون خلال اليوم كان
مقلقًا بعض الشيء